翻訳: HONG RYUN Isa
校正: Takafusa Kitazume
皆さん こんにちは
あなたが もし
何か新しいものを
思いついた時
なぜ それが今
世の中に無いんでしょうか
例えば 何か思いついて
これで特許を取れば
億万長者になれるのではと
思った事もあるでしょう
なぜそれが無いか
理由は三つしかありません
一つ目は
誰も思いつかなかったからです
そうです
あなたが真の発明者です
二つ目は
誰か昔思い付いた事はあったが
作る事が出来なかったからです
だから無いんです
これは技術の進化と共に
できるようになってきます
アニメや映画の世界がそうです
そして三つ目は
いらないからです
いらないから無いんです
会社や研究で
よく起こります
「やった！発明した
何か思い付いた いける！」と思ったけど
大体そういう物は
要らないんです
だから無いんです
そういう罠に陥ります
しかし 思いついた方は
そうはいきません
「私は絶対に発明者だ」と思いたい
信じたくなる訳です
だから だんだん役に立たない事に
気付いてきても
一生懸命特許を出し
モノを作っていきます
そういう事に
なっていきます
最終的には 「おもしろければ
なんでもいいんだ」と
「とにかく これをやるんだ」と
研究を続けていく
訳の分からない
輩が出てきます
その最たる例が
私です
（笑）
あ 良いですね
今日ここ 唯一笑う所ですからね
（笑）
私には こだわりがあります
モノづくりをする際に
確かに いろんな訳の分からない物を
作ってきました
しかしですね 最初にやる事
例えば ピラミッドを造るという
タスクが発生した時
皆さん どうしますか
高さを決めますか
方向、材質、デザインですか？
私は一番最初に
一番上に乗せる
オマケを考えます
ピラミッド自体は
後で考えます
このオマケを
最初に考えて
凄い良いオマケを
思い付いて 初めて
一生懸命ピラミッドを
開発するようにしています
これは仕事で言えば
ただの遊び心に
すぎないかもしれません
でも このオマケを考える事が
一番大事だと
僕は考えます
私の家では
こういうモノづくりをするために
いろんな工作機械を手に入れる事が
小さい時からの夢でした
家電で 「三種の神器」と言うと
テレビ、冷蔵庫、洗濯機ですが
川崎家で
「三種の神器」と言うと
まず 家に旋盤です
（笑）
そして フライス盤
これは2.4トンあります
そして 最後は溶接機です
切って、貼って
モノをつくる最低限のルールですね
(私は) これが無いと
生きていけない変態です
（笑）
私が作ってきた作品を今から
ほんのわずか9つほど紹介します
これは98年に作った
全自動窓ふきロボットです
今では
床を走るロボットがいますが
これは 私が窓を拭くのが
大嫌いで考えたものです
しかし それだけではなく
ショールームに張り付いて宣伝もするという
遊び心を加えた作品でした
2000年には「手ぶらでゴー」という
作品を作りました
これも 海外旅行に行った時
スーツケースが非常に邪魔だった
それで 一生懸命
これを作りました
人間の体の横の部分を
センサーで感知して
自動で横についてくる
ロボットを開発しました
遊び心はこちらです
凹凸のある所に行くと
自分でウィリーをして
バランスを取りながら
凹凸を乗り越えて行く
これを見せるために
わざわざガタガタ道を―
歩かないと
いけなくなります
（笑）
という運命になります
そして 2001年
セグウェイが発表される２か月前でした
きっかけは
子供をベビーカーで押してた時に
ベビーカーがつぶれた状態でも
立って動いたら便利なんじゃないかと思い
バランスをとりながら動く
そして 縦列駐車も簡単にできる
こういったビークルを開発して
実際に動かすところまで
やりました
2002年には
おむすび型の乗り物ですね
全方向に自由に動ける乗り物
「おむすびぃ～」を作りました
見て分かる通り
今の私に比べ
体重が
約20㎏程 重いです
多分仕事のストレス
だったと思います
（笑）
私の家では
ストレスで太る事を
「ふとレス」と
呼んでいます
（笑）
これちょうど「ふとレス」
だったんですね
その時 遊び心としては
行きたい方向に足を出す
そうすると
その方向に動けるように
実はセンサーが見えにくいんですが
ゴマの形になっていて
おむすびになっているという
構造です
見た目も可愛いです
そして 2004年には
この「くるくるりん」
多数の車輪を
二重反転で回転させて
いろんな方向に
動く事ができる
これも全方向移動の
乗り物です
実は 全方向に動くという事より
あれだけの車輪が
グルグル回りながら
一回も止まる事なく
同じ位置に止まっていられる
ここが技術的に
一番難しかった作品です
本末転倒ってやつですね
（笑）
その後は「六角君」
足が人間の足のように
直立ではなく
六角形をした
足のロボットです
腕は一本しかありません
猿のようにつかまって
降りる事も出来ますが
実際に
二足歩行する時は
一本の腕で
バランスを取りながら
体の姿勢の慣性を計算して
歩くという
変わった形をしています
何で腕を
一本にしたんだって
皆さんアンバランスだと
思うんですね
私の祖父は
戦争で片腕をなくし
腕は一本しか
ありませんでした
それでも色んな事が
出来ました
それを見た時に
「決して両腕ある事が―
バランスがいいとは限らない」
と思って
腕一本で歩くロボットを
作りました
そして 2006年です
これは「ムーン」と言って
見た方も
いらっしゃるかもしれない
東京モーターショーや
CEATECでも出しました
実は一番外側のタイヤを
最初に作って
後から中を
作っていきました
一番外側のタイヤの直径が
一番大事です
どうやって決めたかと言うと
相撲の土俵の
1/3の径にしました
という事を まず決めて
その後 中をどんどん
作っていきました
遊び心としては
背中の羽が
ウィンカーになっています
その次の年は
一本のキャタピラーで
いろんな所に行ける乗り物を
作ろうと考えました
ただ動くだけではなく
リモート操縦で
バランス制御しながら
遠隔操作ができる
乗り物を作りました
実はこのキャタピラーは
食堂で流れている
配膳盤のレールなんです
「あの上に乗って流れてみたい」という
発想から
（笑）
単純に
それをつなげて
乗り物を作ってみた
という次第です
その次の年は
「空を飛びたい！」と
意味の分からない事を
言い出して
二重反転の
一人乗りヘリコプターを作りました
わずか8本のネジを刺せば
この形になって
ばらすと
コンパクトな木箱に入る
組み立て式
ヘリコプターです
プロペラの翼端速度は
510㎞に達します
パイロット役は
53歳のおじさんでした
何故 53歳の人に
頼んだかと言うと
将来ある若い人に こんな危ない事を
頼めなかったんです
（笑）
それで この人にパイロットに
なってもらいました
お願いする時に
「死んでくれ」って言って
（笑）
冗談です
その後も
いろんなロボットを
作ってきましたが
2011年に震災があり
大好きだった
ロボットコンテスト―
バイクのレース
実業団のテニスも全てやめて
博士課程に行くと
心に決めました
その時
ちょうど40歳でした
こちらが
今いる研究室の先生です
稲葉先生と言います
全く知らないという人は
手を挙げて下さい
いませんね
ありがとうございます
こちらは「世界最強のロボットの先生」
と謳われています
「一緒に世の中に役立つロボットを
開発しよう」とお願いして
こちらの研究室で
一緒に博士を取っています
余裕で留年してますけれども
まだ 頑張っております
今も現役で学生です
そこで開発したのが
こちらのロボットです
陸・海・空を制する飛行ロボット
要は 津波がきて
水があっても
細い隙間の間も
地面も動けるものを作ろうと
最終的なゴールは
ただ飛ぶだけでは
駄目なんです
はやりのドローンでは
行けないような
狭い隙間を
何とかして通り抜けたい
そういう思いから
開発しました
そして 2012年に作ったのが
マルチフィールド対応
「ムーワ」です
「夢のリング」という
言葉をかけて
マルチフィールドという
英語の文字を並べて
「MUWA」という
文字をあてました
上下どちらでも
飛ぶ事ができ
上空250ⅿからの
撮影も可能です
浮き輪をGPS座標の場所に
行って投下したり
プロペラそのものの
角度が変わる技術を
このクアッドコプターに
私が搭載して実現しました
勿論 たくさん失敗しました
一日100回くらい
転倒を繰り返して
最終的には
わずかな定点に
きっちり立つ事できる技術
そして 倒れて、回って
また 起き上がる
こういう奇妙な動き
いや すみません
エレガントな動きが
できるようになりました
これらを使って
何とかして
当初の目的を果たしたい
立って転がる事で
電気エネルギーは
わずか飛行の1/10で済みます
これである程度
現地まで移動する
そして 最後の目的である
斜めの隙間を通る動きは
ただ転がるだけでは
駄目だという事です
姿勢をある角度で
固定した状態で
転がれないと
いけない
どんな状態からでも
任意の角度になれるよう
プログラムする事が
大事になりました
これらの研究の
総合的・複合的な動きを
ちょっと ご覧いただきたい
スイッチを入れると自動で
立ち上がり
あたかも
一輪車の乗り物のように
動き回る事が出来ます
本体の中心の裏側に
カメラが付いていて
画像処理をしたり
凹凸を検出できます
普通に転がると
左側の斜めになった
脚立の隙間に
勿論
当たってしまいます
ここで 通り抜けれる角度に
自らなって
この状態キープしたまま
まっすぐ進む事ができる
これが非常に新しい
ただ 飛ぶだけではない
飛行ロボットで可能な新しい技術と
私は考えています
そして センシングを行って
戻って行きます
最終的には
先ほど通った角度を
記憶しておいて
戻る時は
すんなりぶつからず
通り抜けができる
技術を実現しました
これをさらに応用して
2013年には
水上で できるようにしようと
外のボディは
発泡スチロールなので
浮いて自由に
グルグル回る事も出来ます
回るだけではなく
水の上の狭い隙間も
通り抜ける事ができ
脚立の向こう側も
通り抜ける事が出来ます
こういった事が出来れば
災害現場で役立つのではないか
と考えました
しかし これだけでは
まだ足りない
やはり計測技術が
必要ではないかと
それで
建屋の中に入った後は
まず飛んで
上から撮影します
そして 横方向は
縦になって転がりながら
入って行き
こうすれば 隙間と天井の隙間を見て
飛行するので
中の立体計測が
可能ではないかと考えました
そうすると
最終的には部屋全体のー
3D計測データを
取る事が出来ます
入口からは
見る事が出来なかった
大きなモーターの
奥のシャフトや
バルブの部分等
きっちり見てこれます
こういった技術を
開発しました
私は こういったロボット技術を
やってきましたが
見方を変えると
戦争の兵器にもなりかねない
特殊な構造となっています
ただ 私はこのロボットを―
「どうしても平和の
技術のために使いたい」と
心に決めています
なので
他のロボット研究者の方も
今日いらっしゃいますが
なんとかして
こういう新しい技術で
平和に役立つロボットを
作っていきましょう
そう願ってます
今日は特に
若い方が沢山います
お年の方もいらっしゃいますね
すみません
そういう方々に私から
メッセージがあります
どんな研究でも
どんな仕事でも
全く無駄な研究は
何一つありません
僕は遊び心があって
初めて
イノベーションが
起こると信じています
モノづくりを
本気でやるには
なんとしても
遊び心が大切だと思っています
そして
もう一つ大事な事は
一生は
一回しかありません
その今からの一生
一回しかない事を
本当に好きな事を
一生涯やりたい
そのための環境作りを
一生懸命やってもらいたい
それは勉強かもしれないし
工作の技術かもしれない
知り合いかもしれない
でも とにかく
その環境を一生懸命整える事を
必ずやってもらいたいと思います
僕は 「自分の可能性を信じて
諦めない事」を
とにかく大事にして
やってきました
皆さん
もし少しでも
これに共感してもらえるなら
こういう遊び心を忘れずに
以上です
（拍手）
そうですよね
（笑）
このまま この変態が
帰る訳にはいかないですよね
お～
（拍手）
少々
うるさいですが
我慢して下さい
（プロペラ回転音）
非常に安定して
飛行する事が出来ます
ボディにTEDxの文字が写ります
自由に飛行できます
ここまでだと
皆さんよく見る
ドローンと同じような
ものですが
ここで
スイッチを入れます
すると 自分で
その角度を計算します
どうですか
回転する事が出来ます
足で蹴っても
倒れません
任意の角度になって
この状態で
角度をキープ出来ます
そして
転がる事が出来ます
ありがとうございました
（拍手）